meu nome é nada guiar eu sou cirurgião
plástico
eu vou contar pra vocês a história da
laura laura ela estava infeliz e
descontente com a sua aparência e ela me
procurou porque ela queria muito fazer
uma cirurgia plástica
ela queria fazer uma abdominoplastia
quer uma cirurgia que tem como objetivo
melhorar o contorno corporal das pessoas
através da retirada do excesso de pele e
de gordura da região abdominal e como
cirurgião plástico o que vocês acham que
eu disse pra ela
como assim não
na verdade a maior parte das pessoas
acredita que o bisturi traz a felicidade
mas isso não é verdade
as distorções no corpo de uma pessoa são
os reflexos de um desequilíbrio interno
que se manifesta internamente e naquele
dia ao invés do bisturi
eu propus uma nova técnica a cocriação
mas antes de falarmos de cocriação eu
quero contar uma história pra vocês que
fez eu pensar e buscar novos conceitos
de saúde
a história de vida e de morte do meu pai
meu pai era diabético fumante e nunca
havia se preocupado com sua saúde
até o exato momento que ele teve um
ataque cardíaco
até o exato momento que ele quase morreu
ea partir daquele dia ele decidiu cuidar
da sua vida
mas na verdade ele estava cuidando dos
sintomas de sua doença
isso é assustador para mim com a maior
parte das pessoas quer controlar sua
doença para viver mais mas não se
preocupa e cuidar da sua própria vida
para evitar essas doenças infelizmente
meu pai veio a falecer
ele faleceu precocemente com 60 anos de
idade
por uma doença facilmente evitável
isso mexeu muito comigo me deixou muito
confuso fiquei com muita raiva
fiquei angustiado eu não sabia o que
fazer naquele momento eu sentia que
precisava encontrar o culpado para cá o
meu coração eu refleti muito e eu
descobrir se o culpado
na verdade não foram as pessoas que
mataram o meu pai e que a culpa também
não era minha que era médico
na verdade a culpa era de uma
mentalidade antiga mentalidade a onde
nós temos a idéia de terceirizar os
nossos problemas
uma mentalidade onde as pessoas não
participam ativamente no processo de se
manter saudável e depois de ter vivido
essa experiência eu não podia mais
praticar medicina como antigamente eu
tive que buscar novos conceitos de saúde
eu precisava reinventar minha profissão
e foi nesse exato momento que eu
encontrei a cooperação cocriar foi um
termo que surgiu no mundo dos negócios
que significa a participação ativa do
cliente na fabricação do processo de um
produto ou do serviço e na área da saúde
o que isso significa
significa trazer o paciente pra dentro
do seu processo de saúde significa fazer
com que o paciente se comprometa com que
ele está pensando mas como funciona na
prática
lembra da laura então agora eu vou
contar pra vocês como laura ficou assim
depois de sete meses sem o uso do
bisturi
afinal criar e fazer juntos e juntos nós
iniciamos uma conversa ela me disse que
ela gostaria de fazer uma cirurgia
eu como médico naquele momento eu tive
que me posicionar
eu falei laura fazer uma cirurgia nesse
momento é uma solução de curtíssimo
prazo
a mesma coisa que tratar o sintoma ao
invés da origem do problema
e quando eu disse isso eu fiz ela pensar
e pensando ela chegou na compreensão do
que estava acontecendo na vida dela e
ela teve uma constatação
ela havia abandonado
ela havia se tornado a origem do seu
próprio problema e no momento que ela
percebeu isso
a sua postura mudou é impressionante
como a tomada de consciência promove
mudanças instantâneas naquele exato
momento a laura chegou pra mim
doutor o que nós dois podemos fazer
juntos para reverter o que aconteceu e
criar uma solução efetiva e duradoura
então reiniciamos a nossa conversa
porque é assim na cocriação essa troca
que a gente vai construindo o tratamento
laura começou a falar de seus medos suas
angústias suas motivações e baseado em
tudo que ela havia me contado e todo o
conhecimento que eu tinha
nós começamos a construir um tratamento
para lauro
eu fiz uma série de sugestões sugestões
de algumas mudanças de vida que ela
mesma deveria promover começamos a
conversar sobre a adoção de hábitos
alimentares saudáveis ea prática de
atividades físicas
conversamos sobre cuidar das suas
questões emocionais porque ela tinha
está muito preparada por uma série de
mudanças que iriam acontecer
ela tinha que aprender e assimilar toda
essa novidade mas o principal é que
tinha que usar isso para potencializar a
sua vida
de acordo com todas essas sugestões
nós começamos a decidir o tratamento
escolhemos uma série de profissionais de
especialidades que esse complemento
porque nós precisamos precisávamos ter a
certeza que todos os procedimentos serão
feitos de uma forma precisa e correta
chamamos uma nutricionista o educador
físico uma esteticista uma fisioterapia
o enfermeiro montamos um time sob medida
para as reais necessidades da laura
nesse momento ela não estava mais
sozinha ela tinha uma equipe por trás
uma equipe engajada e comprometida
torcendo e vibrando muito pelo sucesso
da laura e aí a laura se sentiu a
protagonista ea comandante desse
processo e dia após dia a laura se
reinventou começou a praticar atividade
física regular começou até hábitos
alimentares saudáveis ea sua felicidade
era tão grande que ela começou a
impactar a vida de outras pessoas
estimulando essas pessoas a também se
cuidarem
e quando ela começou a tratar
efetivamente suas questões e emocionais
ela se transformou numa nova mulher e
essa transformação
logo começou a ser fisicamente evidente
e quando essa transformação física
apareceu foi o combustível a mais para
continuar no seu processo e agora o céu
é o limite para laura e hoje esta é a
hora
e hoje ela é a hora
obrigado ig então é eu quero que vocês
prestem atenção nessas duas fotos
a mudança é muito mais profunda do que
simplesmente a parte física ea parte
técnica
quando ela me procurou em fevereiro do
ano passado ela tinha 50 anos de idade
era obesa e pertença pré-diabética
trabalhava excessivamente era adepta dia
dietas milagrosas mas ela achava que
sabia tudo sobre alimentação saudável e
ela teve uma brilhante ideia vou fazer
um abdome uma plastia e vou resolver
todos os meus problemas e hoje depois de
eliminar mais de 25 quilos
és e lauro não pertence nem pré diabetes
seus dados clínicos melhoraram sua vida
se transformou
mas apesar de toda essa revolução ainda
assim foi necessária a cirurgia uma
cirurgia necessária para retirar o
excesso de pele que o seu emagrecimento
havia provocado uma cirurgia necessária
assim mas com um propósito completamente
diferente daquele que ela imaginava
quando havia me procurado pela primeira
vez todos nós aqui somos a laura
inclusive eu dei o exemplo dela mostra
claramente como alguém pode reinventar o
seu papel no processo de se manter
saudável pelo simples fato assumindo a
responsabilidade das decisões da nossa
vida e é esse lindo e poderoso processo
que nós chamamos carinhosamente de
cocriação de saúde
mas a história não acaba que não
um belo dia durante nossas consultas
na hora me disse estou praticando
corrida de rua e eu com aquela vontade
de estimular laura empolgado
o seu treinamento disse laura vamos
juntos até o final do ano eu quero
completar uma corrida de 10 quilômetros
com você eu duvido que você faça isso
comigo e ela aceitou o desafio
ela estava tão motivada tão comprometida
com seu próprio processo que até criou
uma página no facebook o criando laura
só que um belo dia eu vi uma publicação
na página do facebook da hora
hoje estou muito feliz acabei de correr
sete quilômetros e logo vou fazer uma
prova de 10 quilômetros que meu médico
quando eu olhei aquele post eu não sabia
se ria ou se chorava
eu pensei meu deus
o máximo que a vida é corrida em toda a
minha vida até que ele exatamente eram
seis quilômetros
laura já estava nos 7 literalmente
eu tive que correr atrás da laura foi o
tremendo exercício só que dessa vez foi
diferente
foi um exercício de humildade eu tive
que aprender como o paciente aprender a
criar a minha própria saúde
aprender a cuidar de mim e cinco meses
depois essa nossa conversa eu e laura
completamos nossa primeira prova de 10
quilômetros juntos e hoje eu acredito
com todas as minhas forças que a
cocriação potencializando
potencializando enfocando o potencial
transformador das pessoas
sinceramente pode mudar esse mundo e
essa é uma idéia que merece ser
compartilhada